Bienvenidos en el video anterior les
expliqué que si yo aplico una fuerza F a
un objeto que tiene una masa m y está
inicialmente estacionario y con esta
fuerza F hago que este objeto se mueva
una distancia d esta fuerza multiplicada
por la
distancia va a ser
igual la
fuerza F multiplicada por la distancia d
es igual a
de la masa por la velocidad final al
cuadrado y bueno quedamos que esta
parte esta sección que lo voy a cambiar
de color esto es nuestra definición de
trabajo que lo vamos a este indicar con
la letra W
y esta otra
sección la definimos como la energía
cinética lo pongo como se maneja en
inglés kinetic Energy o
k y bueno
eh se define la energía cinética como la
cantidad de trabajo que se necesita
poner en un objeto o aplicar a un objeto
para que pase de un estado de reposo a
un estado de movimiento ha alcanzar una
velocidad
actual Entonces es
eh la fuerza que le Tuve que aplicar
estos está el objeto
detenido le aplico la fuerza y cuando
llega acá a esta
distancia este objeto que tiene la misma
masa y se movió o lo empujamos a una
velocidad final
B bueno esta su trabajo es igual a
1/2 su masa por la velocidad al cuadrado
y bueno si los números los confunden
Bueno si si las letras los confunden
digamos que tengo que la masa es
igual a 5
kg la velocidad final es 7 M sobre
segundo y diremos que la energía
cinética de este
objeto energía cinética es igual a bueno
vimos es un medio de la masa por la
velocidad al cuadrado entonces va a ser
la mitad de 5 por el cuadrado de 7 es
aproximadamente esto es igual a
125 New por metro o También conocido
esta unidad como
joules es igual a 125
joules pero ese si aplicamos números en
cuanto conocemos este dato de la
velocidad aú cuando no conozcamos Qué
ocurrió Cómo fue que llegó esta fuerza a
este objeto simplemente calculamos su
energía cinética a 125 joules nosotros
inmediatamente sabemos que esa es la
cantidad de trabajo que fue necesario
aplicar al objeto no sabemos cómo se
aplicó ese trabajo pero sí sabemos la
cantidad de trabajo necesaria para
acelerar este objeto a 7 m por segundo
veamos otro ejemplo y en esta ocasión en
lugar de empujar algo en la dirección
horizontal y acelerarlo les voy a
Mostrar un ejemplo donde vamos a empujar
algo hacia arriba pero su velocidad en
realidad no va a cambiar vamos a limpiar
la pantalla en este ejemplo vamos a
tener igual un objeto de masa
m pero que va a ser
eh elevado hacia
arriba con una fuerza que es la masa
bueno que es igual en magnitud a la
fuerza de gravedad que este caso es la
masa por la aceleración de la gravedad
en el sentido hacia arriba y vamos a
Elevar este objeto
a de aquí Ay Dios acá a una altura H
Bueno vamos a llamar la H para
estandarizar noos con la nomenclatura
este
estándar y bueno recordamos que
nuestra fórmula fue
por distancia es igual a la masa por
la
aceleración por la altura en este caso
la distancia va a ser hacia arriba va a
ser la altura y la fuerza es la fuerza
que estamos usando para Elevar este
objeto imagínense que es un elevador que
ya se está moviendo porque ustedes
necesitarían aplicar una fuerza
ligeramente mayor a la fuerza de
gravedad para lograr que el objeto se
mueva pero digamos que el objeto Ya se
está moviendo a una velocidad constante
y bueno por ejemplo podos tener un
elevador y sabemos que el trabajo
realizado por lo que se está jalando al
elevador si lo dibujamos Aquí vamos a
dibujar un ladito vamos a esta cajita
verde es nuestro
elevador tiene una masa digamos de 10
kg y está sujeto por un cable
y está subiendo a una distancia de 100
m Entonces el trabajo lo Está realizando
el cable que está sosteniendo el
elevador la tensión en este cable
Nosotros sabemos que el trabajo
realizado es la fuerza necesaria para
jalarlo hacia arriba superando la fuerza
de gravedad asumiendo que el elevador no
tiene aceleración Porque si el elevador
estuviera acelerando hacia arriba
Entonces la fuerza aplicada a este sería
mayor que la fuerza de gravedad Y si el
elevador estuviera acelerando hacia
abajo si estuviera digamos que
deteniéndose hacia arriba Entonces la
fuerza aplicada sería menor que la
aceleración de la gravedad pero ya que
el elevador tiene una velocidad
constante hacia arriba sabemos que la
fuerza que jala hacia arriba es
completamente igual a la fuerza que
jalaría hacia abajo digamos que no hay
fuerza neta por lo que la gravedad y
esta fuerza están
e en el mismo nivel por lo que no habrá
cambio en la velocidad Son fuerzas con
igual magnitud pero en diferente
dirección Esta es Eh mi fuerza masa por
la
aceleración y bueno mi fuerza de
gravedad sería en sentido contrario
sería hacia abajo y Cuál es esta fuerza
que es la misma magnitud bueno son los
10 kg por la aceleración de la gravedad
que es 9.8 m sobre segundo
cuadrado Y en este caso queremos
calcular el trabajo pues va a ser eh
decíamos
nuestros 10 kg por 9.8 m por segundo
cuadrado por la distancia o la altura
que son 100 m y esto es igual a
9800 New Met o
9800 j
Bueno entonces cuánto trabajo fue puesto
en el elevador o en el objeto Ya hicimos
el cálculo 9800 joules de trabajo o
energía al final de mover el objeto 100
m hacia
arriba noten que no hay cambio de
velocidad La pregunta es Dónde está toda
esa fuerza que se puso en el objeto la
la respuesta aquí es que el trabajo Fue
transferido en algo llamado energía
potencial o en inglés potential
Energy pe energía potencial la energía
potencial se define como la masa por la
aceleración de la gravedad por la altura
y bueno la aceleración de la gravedad
esto es asumiendo que estamos en el
planeta tierra si no este valor
cambiaría por qué se llama energía
potencial porque en este punto si el
elevado Ya lo tenemos aquí arriba de los
100 m
eh En este caso bueno la energía o el
trabajo que tuvo que ponerse en este
objeto Y en este caso se trata de la
energía potencial gravitacional el
trabajo tuvo que ponerse en este objeto
para que alcanzara esta altura pero
ahorita el objeto no se está moviendo no
hace nada así que no tiene energía
cinética pero ahora tiene mucho
potencial para realizar trabajo Y eso
qué significa después de que muevo este
objeto 100 m hacia arriba en el aire
cuál sería su trabajo potencial bueno
puedo soltarlo y no tener fuente externa
alguna además de la gravedad la gravedad
sigue allí y debido a la gravedad el
objeto caerá si lo suelto se va a caer a
una velocidad eh bastante rápida cuando
llegue al suelo y quizás no pueda
aplicar esto Perdón quizás pueda aplicar
esta energía
alguna máquina o algo así y que esto
haga un trabajo y bueno si esto les
confunde vamos a ver a ver otro ejemplo
vamos a limpiar la pantalla en Entonces
tenemos Este ejemplo donde hay un
objeto con masa de 1 kg y se
encuentra a una
altura de 10
m sobre el suelo el suelo está
aquí
entonces tenemos que en este punto aquí
arriba tiene energía potencial y
quedamos que la energía potencial o
potential Energy pe es igual a la masa
por la aceleración de la gravedad por la
altura y Esto va es igual a bueno 1 kg
de masa por la aceleración de la
gravedad que es 9.8 pero lo vamos a
redondear para facilitar los cálculos a
10 m sobre segundo cuadrado por la
altura que son 10 m y esto nos da igual
a 100
newm
o ya saben 100
joules Entonces nos toma 100 joules de
trabajo levantar este objeto eh 10 m
sobre el suelo y ahora podemos usar
nuestras fórmulas de movimiento para
calcular qué tan rápido caerá el objeto
si lo
soltamos pero aquí vemos que todo esto
de trabajo y energía sí tiene utilidad
tenemos algo llamado ley de la
conservación de la energía la energía No
se crea ni se destruye solamente se
transforma de una forma a otra en este
ejemplo
eh vamos a observar que el objeto tiene
mucha energía potencial y al llegar al
suelo la energía potencial en este punto
va a ser igual a cer0 ya que pues no
tiene altura la definición de la energía
potencial involucra la altura y aquí en
este punto en el suelo pues la altura es
cer0 Entonces no tiene energía potencial
en el siguiente video vamos a ver eh Qué
pasa con la energía potencial que
teníamos aquí que era de 100 joules Qué
pasó con esta energía cuando dejamos eh
caer este objeto En qué se transformó
esta energía potencial nos vemos en el
siguiente video